to
mikon is
them
I'm
still where's my brother Mr Delo I can
assure you it ain't nobody from around
here I will give you 2 hours to find the
man that did this that's impossible or
you bring me to your
people I'm innocent please
no let him rest in peace princess I will
take care of you now and we could use
people like you forever going to face
that
murder aren you two soldiers back where
you came from I need a revolver H and
some ammunition from a winchest did you
have a fight no more I did who was the
enemy
Germans you have my
respect you know we've been hoping
praying for someone like you to come
along save us from our
misery
I underestimated you soldier that ain't
going to happen
again and